alicia and patience
you're back again
i thought you'd have housing by now but
what happened
it's
just
a run around we got matched then it
wasn't a for sure match then it was a
definite match and then we had to come
up with all these documents and
so
been trying to come up with all the
documents and stuff that we have to get
yeah and i've seen this play out with a
lot of different people yeah so um
now i mean i i sent those in yesterday
and so now it's just a waiting game
again
how are things
um
well his patients started school um
we're doing home school on the phone
okay so
since the last time we were here um
child services
came um
because um you know the videos and when
you're gonna get something you probably
lost your job because it's too right um
i i'm i didn't lose my job over that per
se but um
and it's still open to me i can still go
back um once i have my housing
um
but it'd be a long drive to come here
and then go back there yes so you
probably you could find a job like that
yes um yeah closer to home yeah exactly
but what happened with child services
well with child services um
they
they were concerned they drug tested me
i was clean
i'm like please do
um
um now they're just involved in our
lives for the next 30 days because
that's procedure i guess um
and uh
they're just trying to protect a young
child it looks like there
could be problems well
you know she's yeah we're on skid row
you know it's not the best place for
so i've been giving you money for motels
mostly i guess there was a couple days
where i thought you were off to the
valley to your house but yeah well i i
felt bad um continuing to ask
you know for oh my god you have you have
you know you have the ability to like
hold back from asking me
yeah unlike most people here yeah
everybody just asks me all the time so
so in the meantime you're you're in a
place again you know what you and i
think
we kind of talked about this yesterday
there have been so many commenters so
many of my viewers that want to help you
guys
and now you kind of clearly probably
need help as much as ever right
yeah so i i told people i wouldn't do a
gofundme anymore but
i think i think maybe this is probably
the time to maybe try doing it i'll i'll
do like a general gofundme you guys will
probably get the the bulk of it
especially right now when you need it
and then we'll also use it for other
people but but i think that might help
you guys
thank you from being in the situation
where you're scrambling all the time
especially with with your daughter
trying to
go to school and all it's got to be a
struggle right well i'm doing homeschool
with her because
being in limbo you know not knowing
where we're going to be if we're going
to be in a tent or in a hotel or if
we're going to be in the apartment
and
i decided that i was just going to
homeschool her and i did that on the on
the phone
and i'm not
i have a 7th grade education i got my
ged and i did do a little bit of college
but the last time i went to real true
blue school was in seventh grade and i'm
41 now
so i mean what they're doing in fifth
grade sixth grade i didn't even do in
seventh grade you know you hadn't done
it's gotten
so i'm not
i'm not a teacher i i just i feel
overwhelmed with
her school stuff and
well we'll see we'll see what the
gofundme generates and maybe we can even
get you
i i i uh we'll figure out a message for
the school on wheels they contacted me
so i'm gonna try to do some um
tutoring with them they'll be able to
help me a lot i think
but my biggest concern right now is i
have um
i have some medical issues and i i need
to go to the hospital and they're going
to admit me when i go and um so you'll
be out for a while yeah and then at
least a few days the patients will need
it somewhere to go yeah and i have
nobody here and so
my biggest thing is i've been trying to
come up with funds to send her back to
alaska for a week or two
because um my medical stuff is serious
yeah okay so we'll we'll figure this all
out yeah we'll get you guys straightened
out so you can get
patients taken care of while you do that
patients how are you good
what's going on nothing
she's carsick your car's like from what
the bus
they're horrible drivers okay he got
carsick from the bus ride especially the
one yesterday he was an even horrible
driver then today
what's going on in your world what's
going on with your family oh nothing
i've been doing school and i've been
watching tv mostly on the phone because
that's where there has hulu on the big
tv there's nothing really to watch
and eating ice i love the ice
she likes it when we get hotel rooms
school is going all right huh how was
school good home schooling
good how are your turtles
oh they're good they're still alive
yeah
they haven't had babies yet i don't
think they're babies
[Laughter]
i'm glad you've kept them alive
we'll try to keep you
off of skid row until your housing comes
through which is still in the works it's
just oh yeah yeah yeah i got all the
documentation in yesterday
and so now i'm just waiting for the
appointment to go sign the paperwork
which is what we were going to do last
week but i didn't have
all the documentation that i needed to
have so well so for for people who would
like to support your situation and help
you guys out
i'll put up a gofundme that we can do
that with thank you and make your lives
a little bit easier and get patients
away from this
neighborhood
and hopefully
we'll do one more when when you guys get
your housing and
hopefully get patients into school that
would be great to see yes
i just it'll be nice for her to go to
school because like right now she i just
feel like she's so lonely
yeah you know she needs to have friends
too
she needs to get away from me
not for my sake but for her
you're not really going to have kids for
her to play with right but but when
we're in an apartment you know and she's
going to school then yeah that'll be
more normalized exactly existence for
her i don't really want to go to school
i like the homeschooling yeah
get real i think going back to school
[Music]
all right you guys
hopefully uh we can get you guys a
little more stabilized you can get take
care take care of your medical things
and uh
thank you patience you might be going up
back to alaska for a little bit
yeah she's excited about that
cool
all right you guys thank you for coming
by again thank you you look great thanks
you